thank you guys again for coming to
another party again my house is back and
I'm really happy to see that me today
the topic is a school choice and I have
got this put together by reason
foundation they're one of my favorite
organizations ever what is missing in
education reform is courage we talk to
people about how passionate we are about
education reform how we want them to end
this ridiculous system of people getting
automatic tenure and jobs for life no
matter what performance in there and we
say that we need to change these things
they will tell you what we cannot change
them because this would make a certain
group mad at me or we make it hard for
me to get reelected and you say well
that's a squirmish politician but what
about us why are we accept why do we
allow politicians tell there's nothing
that we can do about the problem don't
accept that they cannot change the
problem don't accept that they're
unwilling to put their jobs on the line
to change the problem public schools
private schools nonprofits wills home
schools virtual schools magnet schools
really what we're talking about is the
idea that the money should follow the
kid and the parents should have the
right of exit to choose the kind of
school that they would like the light
Steve Jobs so what's our bumper sticker
that really stay with said we don't care
we don't have to wear the phone company
most of you are a certain age I know
some of you a little younger than me
might not remember the phone company is
a monopoly when you have monopoly you
don't have to care that's what education
is in this country it's a monopoly it's
a cartel and it's got to be broken sure
we need better teachers in the classroom
but the underlying tone of President
Obama's message was we need more Union
teachers we need more public schools
that's not what we need we need parents
and teachers choosing where they send
their students and taking the money with
them because through competition is the
only way we're going to level in any way
educational outcomes in our
country okay guys we're going to do a
short QA and I mean short people who are
already in the system are they going to
get all the things that they've been
promised by the unions and it's just
moving forward we're we're actually
clear of those things the payments
they've been promised contractually it's
virtually impossible the courts have
ruled to overturn them retro actively
and so I don't know that you'll be able
to get rid of those in particular but
there's no doubt that one of the reasons
that that education is in the state that
it is today particularly in California
but throughout the country is because of
union power I mean everything you're
talking about I mean you're is a good
question and everything that we are
talking about the unions are going to
fight against and fun we know they're
going to do that so the best thing I
think we can do is have have as many
fires going at the same time they have a
lot of money but it's not an endless
supply you guys working with any private
capital partners that have created some
creative solutions were you just looking
for this to be a mass initiative from a
groundswell outreach which obviously
will take incredibly long time it used
to be I think people would just give
money to school systems get wasted
people stop giving money give your money
to school systems but only give it if
you can establish a a some type of
program that is really reform minded and
you won't give the money unless they
implement it never gave a damn about
school I don't know about you guys
there's a reason why I like nobody
really is engaged nobody cares about
this is no option since one size fits
all and these are the people behind the
scenes that are tackling the details of
union contracts and City legislators and
going at this problem and hopefully you
know it's the future of America it's a
big deal
you